До пункту с частини першої статті 85
Конституції
України призначити позачергові вибори
президента України на 25 травня
2014го
року
обраним Президентом України є Порошенко
Петро
Олексійович Настав час невідворотних
позитивних
змін армія та її переозброєння зусиллями
вітчизняного військово-промислового
комплексу має стати нашим найголовнішим
пріоритетом збройні сили Національна
гвардія Державна прикордонна служба
служба безпеки отримали відповідні
накази ми будемо наступати і
буде
доки ми не навчимося оборонятися самі і
тепер ми зможемо випускати такі ракети
які здатні летіти значно далі ніж зараз
І це має стримувати нашого ворога бо
його територія теж стає
вразливою нікому не вдасться здолати
Україну ми готові зі зброє в руках
захищати власну землю боротися за кожен
їй клаптик і Нікому її віддавати не
збираємося Слава українському народу
Україні
[оплески]
Слава Я використаю весь свій
дипломатичний досвід щоб забезпечити
підписання міжнародного договору який би
прийшов би на заміну Будапештського
меморандуму
ні з ким не може бути компромісу в
питаннях Криму європейського вибору та
державного
устрою
саме європейський досвід підказує нам що
значну частину повноважень вже зараз
треба делегувати з центру місцевим
органам
влади реформа щодо децентралізації
розпочнеться вже цього року змінами до
Конституції
і україна має все необхідне щоб
забезпечити людям європейський добробут
Україна піднялася на чотири сходинки у
рейтингу всесвітнього банку doing
Business з Нового року мінімальна
зарплата в Україні може зрости вдвічі
для реалізації наших амбітних планів Нам
потрібні не лише мир та єдність країни
але й консолідація всіх патріотичних
проукраїнських і проєвропейських
сил
нації вмирають не від
інфаркту
спочатку їм відбирає мову але за останні
5пть років Ми вийшли з перединфарктного
стану зробили дуже багато і українською
мовою говорить з нами якісний
інформаційний продукт кіно книга радіо і
телебачення розквіт української мови
після століть тотальної русифікації це
місія яку Нам належить звершити питання
про мову завжди було
є і буде питанням про свободу України
про нашу свободу і ніяк
[музика]
інакше Сьогодні я підпишу ухвалений
Верховною Радою закон згідно з яким
борцям за незалежність України в X
столітті присвоєно статус уча боови
[музика]
[оплески]
ді
звершилося цей день вже увійшов в
історію України як священний день день
створення Автокефальної помісної
Православної церкви України день
остаточного здобуття нашої Української
незалежно від Росії та церква що в місті
Константинополі завжди стоятиме на
вашому боці кликаючи наднію підносячи
молитву і працюючи для вашого добра
поступу і зростання в
Христі
сподіваючись що новопостала православна
церква в Україні стоятиме
непохитно нас підтримує ли
світ
це є головним документом який
характеризує співпрацю України і
Європейського Союзу угода про
асоціацію саме заради всіх цінностей
європейських цінностей 3 з по роки тому
українці вийшли на революцію гідності
вимагаюч реформ європейської
інтеграції до
свидания наш ласковий Міша возвращайся в
свой Сказочный
лес народ своє магове слово сказав під
час революційних подій під час спротиву
агресії під час виборів тепер черга за
нами за владою Ми народ що був одірваний
від своєї великої батьківщини Європи
повертаємося до неї остаточно
[музика]
безповоротно